capitalism there's this guy out there I
don't know if you guys know or not his
name is Bernie Sanders
Bernie he was on this show called face
of nation okay and she faced the nation
and she asks a very simple question of
him he's having an event right now
that's 95 that's being sold on
Ticketmaster Ticketmaster that just got
a bunch of heat so credit to her for
asking the question of Bernie and look
how uncomfortable it gets very quickly
promote this book it's okay to be angry
about capitalism and you're here talking
about it I understand we're not the bad
guys you're describing in the book when
it comes to Media but tickets for your
tour apparently are selling for 95 on
Ticketmaster which is Con accused of
anti-competitive behavior you know that
some of your Democrats are criticizing
them aren't you benefiting
you're trying to dismantle first of all
those decisions are made totally by the
publisher and the Bookseller I think
right yes I am just a humble Senator
go back a little bit go back a little
bit some tickets we're going on tour to
promote this book it's okay to be angry
about capitalism and
you're here talking about it I
understand we're not the bad guys you're
describing in the book when it comes to
Media but tickets for your tour
apparently are selling for 95 on
Ticketmaster which is Con accused of
anti-competitive behavior you know that
some of your Democrats are criticizing
them aren't you benefiting yourself
you're trying to dismantle first of all
those decisions are made totally by the
publisher in the Bookseller I think it's
one case we're in one place here in
Washington politics and pros and
independent books are charging some
tickets most of them I think forty
dollars fifty dollars and you get a book
as well so if you want to come you're
going to have to pay 40 bucks I'll throw
in the book for free
events but I don't make a nickel out of
these things
politically but that's again nothing to
do with that that is you wrote a book
probably be the same process
first of all just so you know I I I have
a you know I've been through this with
Simon and Schuster and now we're going
through a penguin you yet to say what
you want to participate in and what you
don't want to participate in do they
force you to go places like your book
that's coming out did they force you and
tell you you better
go sell tickets at Ticketmaster or else
you're fired did they tell you something
like that and your book is a bestseller
it's not like your book sold a thousand
copies your book was a New York Times
bestseller it did and the next one
that's coming up right that's a new one
that's coming up it just came out that
just came yeah they don't force you to
do those things they're very grateful
that I want to do interviews like they
don't like they don't have an authority
you have to do this that's right right
like you just really all up to me so if
he doesn't want to do it he could always
have done like not doing it Bernie
secretly loves capitalism here's what's
so crazy about it watch this he bashes
capitalism writes a book on capitalism
while a capitalistic company prints it
ships it publishes it sells it on Amazon
promotes it on social media and goes
talks about our major media companies
platform all started by capitalism but
capitalism sucks yeah yeah it's like
hypocrisy yeah it's like it's like Greta
thundberg the climate activist lover so
and she's there with her book she sold
you know how many thousands of trees got
killed and chopped down I think it's
because it talks about free education
but if you want to get edgy hit about
what I think I'm going to charge you
yeah it's a comedy here's what I think
is happening with Bernie he's 2 too far
deep when he had no money when he
started off as a senator Congressman or
mayor of whatever Vermont yeah that
story was fine it's okay hey socialism
Democratic socialism it's all good now
that he's 80 something years old he's
made his millions by the way which is
fine by the time you're [__] 80s
if you just contribute to your 401k and
make 150 Grand a year that's normal but
now that he's reached this worldwide
International certainly National Fame
and books are being sold of it and he's
speaking and it's like this his
popularity is at a grand scale I'm
assuming he's grappling with the money
and the fame and the success and the
notoriety versus no uh capitalism was
bad I guess it's like yeah well where
are you yeah which one is it Bernie you
gotta pick a path like he owns them
Bernie what were you saying no I mean
it's interesting because he owns a
multiple property the idea of like not
capital is not owning anything so AOC
and he should be the first one to know
announcing all their properties and not
owning anything sell it all Tom actually
has a very intimate story with Bernie I
don't know if you want to tell the whole
story
no he really does upstairs no watch this
it's actually pretty funny so a
colleague and I are in Vermont visiting
a uh a company in our industry uh the
industry that I was working at the time
and we as I'm going through metal
detector in the uh airport there's this
corner there's kind of a silver haired
gentleman I look it's Bernie he's right
behind me we walk the metal detector yet
and um I kind of bumped shoulders with
them over getting the bags off and I
said oh hello Senator hello how are you
and um we we walk a few steps and my
colleague says Hammer step to the men's
room real quick and Bernie goes in there
so I'm just waiting for my friend to
come out and he comes out and he says
said hi to Bernie Sanders where while we
were both standing there in the bathroom
oh well you were both yeah relieving
ourselves says he said hello and then he
farted incredibly loud
and
I said oh so you know sort of passing
legislation and
they walk out and
so my colleagues goes wow that's a
forever story I said yeah you forever
can say at the Burlington Vermont
airport did he say excuse me he said you
know I don't think he did
Bernie that that's disgusting but listen
when you hear stories like this and and
a guy is again he's human this is this
is the great part about capitalism
sometimes you don't even have to debate
the other person you just bring them you
let them talk and then eventually like
oh there's a leak boom Oh there's a leak
oh there's a leak it's like go ahead
tell us why you believe in socialism
yeah tell us why you're building the
communism Bingo that doesn't work you're
using a capitalistic platform to do what
you're doing here so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you